In 2009 the pinnacle of the franchise, Pokemon
Gold and Silver were remade for the Nintendo
DS, and with the remakes came some added content
that they decided to throw in, one of which
ended up being strangely disturbing.
The event is triggered if you visit The Ruins
of Alph with a special event Pokemon who can
only be acquired in a one time in-store giveaway.
A researcher bumps into you and brings you
down into the ruins, where he says something
feels different, and the Uknown hieroglyphics
on the wall seem to be staring at him.
If you aren’t familiar, Uknown are these
mysterious Pokemon that represent letters
of the alphabet.
This is where things get weird.
You suddenly hear a high pitched laughter
and the screen fades to black.
You’ll next find yourself in a dark temple,
supposedly far off from anywhere you’ve
been before.
After some exposition, you’re brought back
to the temple and asked to choose one of the
ancient circles on the ground.
Upon choosing, your Pokemon will float to
the center of the room and a horde of Uknown
will swirl around you as you’re engulfed
in a huge light.
This animation is graphically not like anything
else in these games, giving you this surrealistic
vibe, but it gets weirder from there.
Creepy Gregorian music starts playing, and
we’re taken through a slideshow of the creation
of the universe, using real life photographs.
I’ve always found the use of mixed mediums
to be creepy, and this is no exception, seeing
man-made cities from our world just comes
as a shock after looking at an entire game’s
worth of this one specific art style.
The event ends with you being given this egg
containing a new Pokemon, before reappearing
in the ruins and the researcher explains that
you just disappeared and reappeared before
his eyes.
The mystery deepens.
While we’re still on The Ruins of Alph,
they are pretty creepy even under the game’s
normal circumstances.
Once you get near the Ruins, you can start
to pick up a strange signal on your radio.
It’s so broken and distorted, it sounds
more like part of some Pokemon creepypasta
than an actual part of the game.
The player is tasked with completing these
ancient block puzzles, each depicting an ancient
prehistoric Pokemon.
The completion of these puzzles opens up a
trap door, leading to the underground tombs
where Uknown will start to randomly appear.
The question is, who could have built this
place all those millions of years ago, and
for what purpose?
Even after completing everything, the mystery
of the ruins is never fully solved.
Another creepy location in the series is N’s
Room in Pokemon Black and White.
N was an orphan adopted by the evil Team Plasma
and one of the more interesting characters
in the series.
He poses the idea of liberating Pokemon from
their trainers as an animal rights type of
thing, but it turns out that his superiors
were just lying and trying separate other
Pokemon trainers from their Pokemon so that
they would have all of the power in the world.
Seeing N’s childhood room shows how manipulated
he was.
They’ve spent tons of money to keep him
occupied, but everything in the room is there
to keep him entertained by himself without
the need for any friends.
He has a trainset, basketball hoop, dartboard,
even his own halfpipe.
You can go back to the room in the sequels,
which take place 2 years after Team Plasma
betrays N. Now the room seems to have been
destroyed, most likely by N, in a rage after
discovering his faux father’s true intentions
and how he was used.
The music box in the room also seems to have
been broken, as the soundtrack sounds much
more sinister.
Perhaps the creepiest part about N’s room
though, can be seen if you examine the half-pipe.
The character observes that it has been damaged
by the scratches of Pokemon.
Did N’s father give him potentially harmful
Pokemon, as part of his plan to turn N against
the union shared by Pokemon and their trainers?
We never fully find out, but it looks grim
based on the evidence presented in the game.
While we’re on the topic of harmful Pokemon,
there are many that look innocent, but actually
have extremely dark descriptions.
Others are just downright terrifying.
“Cofagrigus.
It has been said that they swallow those who
get too close and turn them into mummies.
They like to eat gold nuggets.”
“They pretend to be elaborate coffins to
teach lessons to grave robbers.
Their bodies are covered in pure gold.”
So this Pokemon, Cofagrigus, literally has
been known to swallow adults whole.
It makes you think twice as the 14 year old
protagonist of these games whenever you encounter
one while exploring.
Who knew that your adventure could come to
a close at any moment?
Literally.
Let’s look at another.
“Gengar.
To steal the life of its target, it slips
into the prey's shadow and silently waits
for an opportunity.”
It’s pretty unnerving to consider that something
could be watching you from your own shadow.
Especially if you are the Pokemon Clefable.
Many have theorized that Gengar is actually
the dark version or at least the shadow of
Clefable, haunting it wherever it goes.
Given their identical shape, it’s possible
that the name Gengar is short for Doppelganger
because Gengar is the ghostly double of Clefable.
If such a thing exists, it’s chilling to
think about what else is out there.
Do humans have a shadow entity following them
as well?
Moving on.
Sandygast is a ghost/ground type Pokemon resembling
a sandcastle from Pokemon Sun and Moon.
It’s evolution is called Palossand and they
can be found on the sunny shores of Hano beach.
Sandygast’s entry reads as follows: “It
takes control of anyone who puts a hand in
its mouth.
And so it adds to the accumulation of its
sand-mound body.”
That’s creepy enough on it’s own, but
let’s look at the description of the evolved
form, Palossand.
“Buried beneath the castle are masses of
dried-up bones from those whose vitality it
has drained.”
These tropical beaches don’t seem quite
so bright and cheerful, after learning that.
It gets worse when you consider the context.
Hano Beach is a public beach right next to
two huge resorts.
The place is covered with unsuspecting tourists,
and young children can be found playing at
the resort.
Don’t fall asleep on that beach chair, because
your kid could end up as a pile of bones beneath
these sunny shores if you aren’t careful.
Not all the creepy Pokemon are ghost types,
however.
“Beedrill.
Beedrill is extremely territorial.
No one should ever approach its nest - this
is for their own safety.
If angered, they will attack in a furious
swarm.”
That might not sound that scary, but let’s
not forget that Beedrill are 3 foot tall,
65 pound poisonous bugs with giant stingers
for hands.
I think wasps in our world are already scary
enough as it is.
I do not need a swarm of child-sized Beedrill
coming after me with their glowing red eyes.
The thought of that is enough to make me never
want to go outside again.
With that being said, let’s take a break
from the creepy Pokedex entries, I think we
all could use one, and go inside to some of
the creepy buildings that the world of Pokemon
has to offer.
Take Cinnabar Mansion for example.
It’s the burned down… well, they call
it burned down, but I guess it’s just burned…
mansion of a researcher who had been studying
the legendary Pokemon Mew and attempting to
replicate its DNA.
His journal entries can be found in the mansion,
that is if you make it past the mad scientists
and burglars who have come to scavenge the
remains.
The journals tell of approximately a two year
period where researchers found and captured
Mew, cloned it, and gave birth to Mewtwo.
Mewtwo became far too powerful for them to
handle, destroyed the mansion and fled into
the wild, eventually settling in at Cerulean
Cavern.
Mewtwo is the strongest Pokemon in the game,
so much so that only the Pokemon League Champion
is permitted entry into the cavern.
As for the researcher, I think it’s pretty
obvious what happened to him.
In our real world with emerging technologies
such as cloning and AI, it’s scary to think
about these things growing more potent than
mankind, and what type of damage could possibly
incur.
The most universally recognized creepy location
in the Pokemon world of course, is Lavender
Town, with it’s creepy headache inducing
music frequencies, ghost hands resting on
your shoulder and… no these aren’t all
ghost type Pokemon, some of them are real
ghosts of deceased Pokemon.
The rest of the horror community here on YouTube
has done a fine job covering Lavender Town,
so I’m not going to spend too much time
on it, but it does tie into the next topic…
death of Pokemon.
One theory says that after you defeat Blue
on the SS Anne, since he didn’t have access
to a Pokemon center, he was unable to heal
his Raticate’s injuries properly in time.
The next time you see Blue, in the Pokemon
Tower, the final resting place of Pokemon,
he makes a comment wondering why your character
is at the Pokemon Tower, seeing as how none
of your Pokemon look dead.
When you proceed to battle him, the Raticate
is missing from his party.
I guess you could say that you eraticated
the competition.
OK, that’s horrible.
Another haunted location can be found in the
fourth generation games where you can find
an abandoned house deep in The Eterna Forest
known as the Old Chateau.
Many of the characters who you meet in that
area of the game express fear and anxiety
about the Old Chateau.
Even the gym leader, supposedly the strongest
trainer in that nearby city refused to go
any further than the front gate.
Inside, you’ll find an array of ghost type
Pokemon, and while there don't seem to be
any actual ghosts of dead Pokémon here, what
you'll find may actually be more disturbing.
From time to time you can spot the ghosts
of the little girl who once lived there and
her Butler floating around the manor.
The girl can be seen in the next room over
if you go into one of the bedrooms and the
butler can be seen occasionally on the far
side of the dining room.
It’s not possible to reach and talk to either
of them, but they lack the same walking animations
that all of the other characters have in these
games, and instead, just float across the
screen.
There’s also a painting that watches you
and a flickering old TV despite the fact that
power would have long since been cut off from
this location.
There’s also a book you can find in the
library.
All of the pages are blank other than this
one: Something so peculiar should make off
with the mother.
We don’t know much about the family who
lived in the old Chateau, but it seems like
after some dark spirit made off with the mother,
something happened to the daughter and the
butler causing the father to flee the mansion
and never return.
We see another human ghost character in Pokemon
Black and White.
When travelling across an area known as the
Marvelous Bridge, you may occasionally encounter
a young girl, staring off the side of the
bridge.
If you approach this girl, she will simply
disappear, frightening the man standing to
her right.
Upon further investigation, an old woman will
reveal that a young girl with an Abra used
to play around in the area before the bridge
had been built.
We don’t learn anything else until the sequels,
taking place 2 years later.
The player will stumble upon a location simply
referred to as Strange House, on the opposite
side of the mountain that Marvel bridge is
located on.
Inside the house, you’ll find levitating
objects, and the random furniture thrown about
most of the rooms.
In the library, there are several books, pertaining
to the link between Pokemon and nightmares.
In reading each of these books, they explain
about Cresselia, the anti-nightmare Pokemon;
Darkrai, the nightmare Pokemon, Drowzee, the
dream eating Pokemon; Hypno, the sleep inducing
Pokemon; and some of the moves that these
Pokemon may use to haunt the nightmares of
Pokemon… or people.
Exploring the house will lead you to meet
the ghost girl when she just appears in front
of you, only this time, she’ll speak to
you.
You can encounter her again in a different
part of the house, where she now has new dialogue.
Finally, if you go into the bedroom, she appears
one more time.
With that, she gives you Lunar Wing and disappears.
You can use it to summon Cresselia.
It could be speculated that the girl was trying
to summon Cresselia herself, because all of
her dreams were haunted by the evil Darkrai,
possibly driving her to the breaking point,
and death.
That would explain why she had so many books
about Pokemon, dreams and nightmares.
There is another ghost later on that I’d
like to discuss, but first, let’s look at
some more disturbing Pokedex entries.
I’ll start with the aforementioned Drowzee.
“Drowzee.
It remembers every dream it eats.
It rarely eats the dreams of adults because
children's are much tastier.”
“If your nose becomes itchy while you are
sleeping, it's a sure sign that a Drowzee
is standing above your pillow and trying to
eat your dream through your nostrils.”
The idea of waking up to see this horrifying
thing attempting to suck your dream out through
your nose is terrifying, not to mention that
Dream Eater is one of the most devastating
psychic type moves in the game, powerful enough
at times to bring down a behemoth Snorlax.
Getting your dream eaten sounds like one of
the most painful and scarring experiences
imaginable.
But the horror does not end there.
Drowzee evolves into Hypno.
“Hypno.
It carries a pendulum-like device.
There once was an incident in which it took
away a child it hypnotized.”
So not only do these things look like a creepy
old predator, but they are actually known
to come into children’s bedrooms at night,
hypnotize them, and lead them back out into
the wild, into their nest, where several Hypnos
and Drowzees feast upon the children’s dreams.
Imagine waking up as a child and being in
a dark cave, not knowing where you are or
how you got there, and being surrounded by
an entire horde of these nightmare-inducing
creatures who have kidnapped you and want
to devour the thoughts that occupy your head
during a dream.
The next one is a personal favorite from the
seventh generation of games.
“Mimikyu.
A lonely Pokémon, it conceals its terrifying
appearance beneath an old rag so it can get
closer to people and other Pokémon.”
“Its actual appearance is unknown.
A scholar who saw what was under its rag was
overwhelmed by terror and died from the shock.”
So this is a Pokemon that nobody has actually
seen the true form of.
Except for that one guy.
Apparently Mimikyu disguises itself as a Pikachu
because it’s seen that Pikachu is the most
popular Pokemon among humans and it wants
to be loved by it’s human trainers.
Aww… how adorable.
UNTIL you remember the fact that what is underneath
that cloth, what lies beneath the disguise,
the true form of Mimikyu is something so disturbing,
so obscene, so terrifying that the very sight
of it, will literally scare the trainer, TO
DEATH.
But at least the disguise is cute right?
No.
In Pokemon there is an alternate color palette
for each species which are extremely rare
called Shinies.
Look at the shiny form of Mimikyu.
That’s not shiny at all.
It just looks like it belongs in a Zack Snyder
movie.
Wouldn’t want to run into one of those in
a dark alley.
Oh yeah, that’s the other creepy thing about
Mimikyu.
You can only find it in one place, an abandoned
convenience store at the end of a broken forgotten
road.
When you first meet Mimikyu, you go into a
secret backroom where your camera turns on
all on it’s own.
You can then examine the cold, dark little
room and discover that it’s plastered with
all these joyful pictures and magazine clippings
of Pikachu.
So it seems like Mimikyu is either obsessed
with Pikachu or absolutely hates them, which
is creepy either way you look at it.
Then, somehow Mimikyu just appears behind
you and initiates a battle.
I’m just glad to be the character player
in that situation and not Pikachu.
Imagine you are Pikachu.
You go into this room and find all these photos
of yourself plastered around.
Ones you don’t even remember being taken.
Then you turn around… and someone in a costume
resembling you is standing there… blocking
the only exit.
While Pikachu and Mimikyu do share some similarities,
another interesting pair are Cubone and Shedinja.
“Cubone.
It always wears the skull of its dead mother,
so no one has any idea what its hidden face
looks like.”
“Shedinja.
A discarded bug shell that came to life.
Peering into the crack on its back is said
to steal one's spirit.”
Both of these Pokemon hide inside of the skeleton
of another Pokemon in their evolutionary line,
refuse to show their faces and undoubtedly
have some personal issues.
Here’s another Pokemon that looks like it
would make a great pet, but upon further inspection,
you may want to stay miles and miles away
from.
“Espurr.
The organ that emits its intense psychic power
is sheltered by its ears to keep power from
leaking out.”
“It has enough psychic energy to blast everything
within 300 feet of itself, but it has no control
over its power.”
The eyes on this Pokemon are already a little
bit unnerving, and the teeth don’t really
help, but if you try to play with this Pokemon’s
ears, the look it gives you is one that will
be burned into your memory in the worst way
possible.
Yep, the sound you just heard comes from this
Pokemon, Drifloon.
“Drifloon.
Stories go that it grabs the hands of small
children and drags them away to the afterlife.
It dislikes heavy children.”
This Pokemon might look like a balloon you
would pay too much money for at a fair, but
it’s actually a ghost type Pokemon, and
like many of the creepy Pokemon on this list,
it abducts children.
What is it with Game Freak and child abduction
anyway?
I think we’ve all had the childhood moment
of letting go of a beloved balloon.
Maybe we should just be glad that the balloon
lets go of us.
Before I get to what I see as the creepiest
thing to have happened in the Pokemon franchise,
let me tell you about something that may have
not been intentionally creepy, but I found
rather off-putting anyways.
There is an area called Mt.
Moon, which you go through many times in the
first two generations of games.
What I never realized for the longest time,
was that going through Mt.
Moon Square on a Monday night in Pokemon Gold
and Silver resulted in a special event.
So when I accidentally stumbled upon this
and heard this strange music in a location
that I had rolled though many times with no
music change, I was a bit shook.
I’ll just roll the clip.
The noises that they make are so disturbing,
it’s like there’s some kind of dark undertone.
Then the way that rock just appears there
is almost like a jumpscare.
I guess the story goes that the Clefairy come
from outer space and the rock is a meteor
that they summon with their dance.
I had played the game for so long before discovering
that little scene, so it just seemed so unreal
to me when it finally happened.
Alright, it looks like we’ve reached the
number one scariest thing in all of Pokemon.
I’ll just set it up for you a little bit.
In Pokemon X and Y there is a lot to explore
in the biggest city, Lumiose City.
It’s probably the best part of the game:
you can roller blade around, the music is
great and there’s plenty to explore.
Then this happens.
Yep.
Then she just disappears.
It’s never explained.
You never see her again.
Nobody on the internet has any idea who this
girl is, or why this happens.
I was kind of tired and dozing off when it
happened to me, so I think it shocked me even
more.
I kind of thought that I had dozed off and
had weird dream.
The music stops.
The way she just slides across the screen
is very unsettling.
I actually had to look it up online to make
sure it was real.
Afterall, maybe I had one of those fabled
haunted cartridges.
Honestly, the only reason I can even imagine
this is in the game is as a response to the
growing genre of Pokemon creepypasta online.
It seems kind of like something that would
happen in one those stories where the cartridge
is hacked or haunted and the game behaves
in some strange or creepy way.
Maybe the developers put this in to bait people
into writing their own stories and theories,
as a sort of viral marketing campaign built
into the game.
If that is the case, then I guess it worked,
because here I am talking about in front of
you people right now.
By the way, I may do more videos on Creepy
Things in non-horror media if you’re interested
in seeing them, so let me know by answering
this poll right now.
I also haven’t even covered half the creepy
things in Pokemon, so if you want me to do
Part 2, leave a comment and tell me to make
Part 2.
And if you’re new to the channel, I’m
known as CZ.
I make horror films and I do these narrations,
so here’s the deal I’ll make with you.
If you’re interested in creepy stuff, like
you just saw, I can get you more of that.
All you have to do is two things.
First, subscribe to CZsWorld, for new horrors
every week.
Second, ring that Victreebel for notifications.
If you don’t ring the bell, you won’t
be able to see any of my videos.
That’s just how YouTube works now.
So, if that all sounds good to you, then I
will see you in the next one.
Assuming we both survive.